Speaker 1: All right, this is super interesting.
You guys may remember we've been covering this
incredible double standard, this incredible
hypocrisy where Fox News hosts and many in
right wing media have been slamming the Joe
Biden vaccine mandate protocol requirement
in which large employers with more
than 100 employees have to either
get their employees vaccinated, get proof
that their employees are vaccinated,
or they have to test their unvaccinated employees
once a week. Now, Fox News has implemented a much
stricter protocol where you either need to be
vaccinated or test daily and you're required to
wear a mask when working on location in certain
areas. So the FOX protocol, the FOX requirement,
the FOX guidelines call it whatever you want. It
is stricter stricter than the ones outlined by Joe
Biden. Another Fox host was confronted about this.
This is really interesting. This is Pete Hegseth,
who's a big anti Biden guy, big bomb thrower, and
he was interviewed by media, its editor in chief
Ed McLaughlin. And when he was confronted with
this double standard where Hegseth is regularly
railing on the Biden protocol. But Fox, as his
employer's protocol is stricter, he first wasn't
really sure what to say. Then he resorted to
attacking media, which might not surprise you.
Let's take a look at this very instructive.
Speaker 4: There was a vaccine or test
requirement at the Patriot Awards, which
is very similar to the policy at Fox News.
Do you have an issue with Fox News having a
policy like that, which is effectively the same
as Biden's vaccine mandate for big businesses?
Speaker 3: I. You don't you're not mandated to
get vaccinated because you can get a test
Speaker 1: right now, remember, it's the
same thing with Joe Biden. You're not mandated
to get the vaccine because you can get a test.
Speaker 3: I'm not in charge of it. I don't make
the calls, but either you. You have the option
to get a test, so you're not it's not actually a
complete vaccine mandate, and that's fine. I mean,
it's not my call. So I'm grateful for the
people that provide us this opportunity and
and the show went off without a hitch.
Speaker 4: Right. But it's just that,
you know, Joe Biden's vaccine mandate it for big
businesses has been the subject of criticism,
and that's even less stringent than the one at Fox
News, right? It requires weekly testing as opposed
to daily testing. So I'm curious as to why you
have an issue with the Joe Biden vaccine mandate,
but no problem with the one at Fox News.
Beautiful. What do you want me to say?
Speaker 1: Well, answer the question, say, for
example, well, I'm doing it to get clicks or
it's our editorial position, and it's totally
hypocritical. Like, what do you want me to
say? Answer the question, Pete.
Speaker 3: I mean, ultimately,
companies have prerogatives. What the government
should be doing is telling them what to do.
The government shouldn't be telling them
what to do. Every company has its own
policies, and I'm beyond grateful for the
opportunity to work with Fox News Channel.
And it does things that no other organization
does, including your organization media.
Speaker 1: So now he just goes
into attacking the interviewer
Speaker 3: as part of the trash heap of left wing
media that does the same thing everyone else does.
That's why we're number one. I mean, I can't even
imagine with the clicks are on your site. Is it
like 15 people a day, like only journalists in New
York City? And click on that 16. But there are the
only people that read media. I keep asking, could
you read, read the Fox News channel? So you guys
want to network and do your thing? It's cool.
Speaker 1: It's funny to say it's nit picking
to point out that Fox News has been waging a
propaganda war against Biden's vaccine mandate
while having a stricter mandate for its own
employees. Pete Hegseth calls that nit picking.
Speaker 3: I could not be more
grateful for the Fox News.
Speaker 1: Okay, so there it is. So he eventually
comes across something that sounds kind of like an
explanation, which is, Hey, listen, I'm fine with
private companies doing what they think is best,
but they shouldn't be told by the government
that that's what they had to do. But in
in getting to that explanation, he first has to
attack media to get there and insult them and say,
you guys only get 15 clicks and this
is this is actually very common.
Remember when Tucker Carlson was confronted with
the same thing? His reaction was just as bizarre?
Speaker 4: OK, so I have a question here about
Fox News. Yeah. You said Fox News has no vaccine
mandate. But according to Newsweek, the company
requires unvaccinated employees to submit to daily
COVID testing, which is stricter than Biden's
mandate, which calls for weekly testing
by businesses that employ more than 100
people. Is Fox News denying the civil liberties
of its employees by being stricter
than President Biden? Fair question.
Speaker 3: I don't know. I mean, you should
probably ask Newsweek. It sounds like they got
a pretty precise handle on WhatsApp. Yeah.
Hey, if it's wrong, I mean, if I'm wrong,
yeah. Yeah, it's it's it's completely wrong. As
I noted the other night, I'm not, you know. So
what is the policy and can you tell to speak
for the company on this? Because I don't run
the company and I'm not, you know, I'm just going.
Speaker 1: Now, that's very disingenuous. Tucker
could just speak to his experience with the
policy as an employee. He doesn't have to speak
on it as an employer. It's very disingenuous
Speaker 3: company. My personal preference is
that Fox News would, you know, make a statement
about what its policies are. But I think like a
lot of companies, you know, they're hesitant to
do that because like, why would you even want
to get involved in that conversation? Here's
the bottom line. You know, there are a lot of
infectious diseases out there, a lot and a lot
with much higher mortality rates than COVID 19.
And you know, there's HIV.
Speaker 1: So then as a reminder,
he goes into kind of comparing and equating COVID
vaccination and COVID to HIV, which is, of course,
an insane analogy. Given that HIV is sexually
transmitted, you can't sneeze on someone and give
him HIV. There's no vaccine for HIV. I mean, every
time that they are actually confronted with this,
it's a fair question. Every time they know
that they're stuck in an inconsistent position
and they either get angry and turn to insults
or they do. What about ism? So nice job there
by media. It's Aiden McLaughlin and Pete Hegseth
looking kind of like a doofus, I must say.